PERCENTAGE.
AND LOOKING MORE FITTING BETWEEN
A SHORTHANDED GOAL AND IT WAS NY
PLAY AND THEN FLIPPING IT UP ANE
THEMSELVES A BETTER ANGLE AND S.
FROM
OFF TO THE SIDE, THAT ONE BEATS
MARC-ANDRE FLEURY RIGHT IT.
CREATING A LOOR HARTMAN AND ITS.
MINNESOTA FRONT.
IT WOULD MEAN THAT IT IS HIS COO
KIRILL FRONT. ERIKSSON-EK ON THE
MINNESOTA WILD SETTLED DOWN IN E
GOLIGOSKI.
HE GETS
GREENWAY.
STILL WITH THE PUCK.
HE SEN TO
HARTMAN.
OVER TO ZUCCARELLO AND T ADVANTE
HITS THE DEFENDER COMING GREAT E
TO SHOOT IT AND WHEN HIS BELLY A
PRETTYNOT GET IT OUT OF THE ZONE
AND GET ACROSS THE GOAL LINE
OF THE
NET BY SPENCE AND FINALLY
YOU CAN DO THAT WHEN YOU ARE UP
BY THREE GOALS. AREA HERE AND YE